Charlemagne, you called your meeting divine,
and Anita, you said it was magical.
Why did those words and feelings transpire?
Absolutely.
So, when I wrote the book I had this time,
it was during 2020, right, when I finished it.
And there were so many things going on in the world,
and I was like, you know what,
it's time for this book to come out.
And then my best friend Yadi said,
"You know what, I'm gonna go to the ocean."
And she's like, "I'm gonna ask Yemaya,"
who is the main character of the book,
who's also a goddess, who is a black mermaid.
Yes.
And she's like,
"I'm gonna ask what you need to do with this book."
So she went and she heard
you need to give it to Charlemagne.
Wow.
Yes.
And so she did, and two days later
he called me and he was like,
"Do not sign with anyone else,
I'm putting this book out."
Anita, what was your inspiration for this book?
Okay, so first of all I have to say,
before I say the exact inspiration,
that growing up,
you played such a huge part in my development.
I did?
Yes, you did.
And because as, as a magical child,
that's how I call myself
because I could see things before they happened.
I would see spirits within my family.
Everyone knew when someone was pregnant.
And, so, when I saw Firestarter,
I felt like I was seen, I was heard,
I'm trying not to cry right now,
because you played such a huge part
in the development of my magical gifts.
Wow.
And, so, I think for a lot of people,
'cause I've had this conversation with a lot of people,
and what is really amazing about that
is how fiction stories can come in and bring real healing.
Uh-huh.
Right? In reality.
And so that's what Shallow Waters does.
And I've brought in Yemaya, who is an a Orisha.
She is a Yoruba goddess, the goddess of the ocean.
She is a mermaid.
She was said to have watched over our ancestors
as they went over the Middle Passage.
And when I was like,
"Okay, there was a black mermaid
that watched over my people as they came over."
You know, they, they not necessarily like,
so she would watch over the ones
that either were thrown over or fell overboard.
And also our, our ancestor's souls who made it
so that we can be sitting here right now,
having this conversation.
Well, we all need more optimism in our lives.
So, Charlemagne and Anita
are going to share some of their secrets
to creating positive energy.
Charlemagne, what's your ultimate tip
for bringing good vibes?
Be a blessing to other people.
Like I always feel like, you know,
regardless of how you're feeling that day,
(audience clapping)
like, regardless of how you're feeling that day,
if you do a good deed for someone,
like a genuine good deed just because,
I think it, it automatically will make you feel better.
That's genuinely what, what, what gets me off.
And, Anita, you have a small exercise that people can do?
Yes, I do.
Are we about to reach for the ceiling?
Yes we are.
(Charlemagne laughing)
So, this is an amazing exercise called the yes breath
that I learned from my tantra coach,
who, her name is Psalm Isadora.
She's now passed and is in the ethers.
But it is an amazing breath that we can all use
if we're ever going to an interview
or something where you want more energy.
It will bring the energy into you.
And so, everyone, if we can all stand up.
Okay.
We'll do this.
All right.
Let's do it.
Let's try this, I'm in.
And what we're gonna do
is we're gonna place our hands up in the air,
and you're gonna imagine an intention, right?
An intention that you want in your life.
Imagine that it's right up there on the ceiling
and you can bring it down into your body
by bringing your arms down and saying yes.
Right?
And, we're gonna yell it out loud
so that our ancestors hear, so that God hears,
so that all the spirits hear.
And, ready?
Yes. Oh, I mean uh-huh.
(all laughing)
(everyone shouting yes repeatedly)
Keep those hands up.
Feel that energy that you just made in your body.
Whoo!
Bring your energy down
ah, and say thank you for yourself for taking this moment.
Thank you.
Thank you, Anita.
Thank you so much for that beautiful ritual.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
And make sure you go get Shallow Waters by Anita Kopacz.
First time I read it, I said to myself
I had to let my daughter read this
because it truly is like a healing journey,
especially for young, for young girls.
So, please, make sure you go get Shallow Waters.
(all clapping)
Nice stocking stuffer.
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes yes! All right!
Don't forget to catch The God's Honest Truth
with Charlemagne the God,
Friday's on Comedy Central, 10:00, 9:00 central.
And you can get your copy of Shallow Waters
on sale right now.
(upbeat music)